[Música]
bom dia pessoal está todo mundo pronto
para descobrir qual é o superpoder de
cada um aqui assistindo às palestras é
fica claro de que todo mundo que sobe
aqui é super poderoso né não é cada um
tem um superpoder é muito bacana isso
mas mais importante do que a gente que
está aqui falando é ajudar todos nós que
estamos aqui hoje a descobrir o nosso
super poder
você já parou para pensar qual é seu
poder
todo mundo tem um superpoder todos nós e
e descobrir se superpoder a gente vai
ver ao longo dessa apresentação que leva
tempo e dá trabalho
às vezes a gente acha que já sabe qual é
e depois descobre que não é e faz parte
da nossa vida da nossa jornada descobriu
superpoder e para ajudar a gente a
descobrir nosso super poder eu queria
contar quatro histórias pra vocês
a primeira delas a de um garoto lá do
interior que tinha que andar todos os
dias mais de cinco quilômetros pra poder
chegar até a escola
debaixo de sol e chuva do dia após dia
a segunda história de um jovem sonhador
pai de uma menina de que com dois meses
depois seu pai ficou desempregado depois
uma outra história de um caipira que
chega para trabalhar na cidade grande
imagina se o até hoje eu me perco no rio
de janeiro não fico pensando alguém que
chegaram são paulo sem saber luro do
acordo a linha do metrô qual ônibus
pegar se está indo para o norte para o
sul e por último a história de um
empreendedor
para o sucesso falou o calor finalmente
conseguiu chegar lá e se eu perguntasse
para vocês qual seria o superpoder essas
pessoas só seria o garoto lá que andava
todo dia que a gente pode até imaginar
qual é o superpoder desse garoto agora o
cara que conseguiu ficar desempregados e
um pai com dois meses ele é seu super
demitido ou super desempregados
é interessante a gente fala de
superpoder porque até os vilões têm
superpoderes para quem gosta de filme de
super-herói é bacana ver porque para
cada poder
do lado do bem existe um contraponto
outro poder lá do lado do mal e o que
difere o que faz é é no fundo porque o
vilão mesmo sendo super poderoso ele
sempre pede no final isso às vezes
acontece com a gente nós temos um super
poder
só que a gente não sabe usar esse super
então quando a gente fala de superpoder
eu tenho que olhar pra dentro
eu tenho que me conhecer e entender
quais são as minhas limitações
aonde eu preciso melhorar então tem um
exemplo que eu gosto de contar que era
aquela pessoa que é paciente
o mundo pode estar acabando
segundo turno da eleição presidencial no
brasil naquele clima bom né
nada tensa mas aquela pessoa se mantém
paciente consegue trazer os dois lados
para a mesa consegue manter a calma
resolver um conflito
só que essa mesma paciência
ela pode estar impedindo essa pessoa de
procurar um emprego novo
porque ela já não gosta mais de onde ela
trabalha
ela não gosta do chefe dela não gosta do
que ela faz ela poderia estar sendo
feliz em outro lugar
só que naquele momento aquela
característica dela deixa essa pessoa
com formada e esse é um dos segredos de
descobrir o seu super poder no fundo
o superpoder é aquilo que a gente faz é
a nossa atitude
eu posso usar a minha característica
como o paciente para resolver um
conflito
só que se eu não entender do que eu sou
feito aquilo que me torna único naquilo
que eu sou bom
essa mesma característica vai se
transformar numa pessoa com formada com
a vida e é engraçado porque se começa a
falar isso
você começa a ver se os rostos de vocês
já pensando né
puxa vida aquele dia eu me dei bem por
causa do meu super poder naquele dia me
dei mal por causa do meu super poder e é
assim mesmo a gente né
ao longo da nossa vida a gente vai se
conhecendo vai se descobrindo vai
entendendo naquilo que a gente é bom
naquilo que a gente pode ser melhor e é
uma caminhada
o que é importante
todos nós temos um superpoder todos o
que acontece às vezes a quem aqui
acontece com várias pessoas mas assim
venho e chama você é fala que o seu
super poder é um defeito e o que não
pode não pode acreditar nisso porque é
defeito qualidade todos nós temos agora
é muito bacana quando conseguimos pegar
um defeito um ponto fraco nosso
trabalhar esse ponto fraco e usá lo a
nosso favor
e é nesse momento que ele se torna um
superpoder
e vocês querem ver como isso é muito
simples
imagina você para uma entrevista de
emprego para um cargo que você não tem
experiência
então a sua falta de experiência é seu
ponto fraco é seu defeito
só que se você chega a própria próprio
entrevistador e logo de início e se abre
com ele fala olha eu não tenho
experiência mas a minha vontade vai
compensar a falta dela percebe que nesse
momento já me reconheci já expulso
a minha fraqueza o meu ponto fraco e
comecei a usá lo a meu favor
então nesse momento eu acabei de
adquirir um superpoder ea vida é feita
disso são micro superpoderes me
situações pequenas que a gente vai
aprendendo vai trabalhando vai
melhorando e cada vez mais andando para
frente seguindo adiante e se eu dissesse
para vocês que eu sou essas quatro
pessoas é quando eu perdi o emprego lá
em 99
foi muito engraçado porque eu levei anos
e anos para descobrir que eu tinha
perdido o emprego dos sonhos na empresa
dos sonhos no momento mais crítico da
minha vida onde eu não poderia ter
perdido o emprego por conta da minha
teimosia só teimoso pra caramba
imaginem só 99 nós estamos falando quase
de 20 anos atrás interior empresa
familiar eo teimoso aqui querendo vender
pela internet
um dia meu chefe chegou pra mim olha
fabrício
sinto muito mas você está demitido
só que por outro lado quando eu era
criança que tinha que caminhar todos os
dias para ir à escola é foi a minha
perseverança minha persistência que me
ajudou a não desistir nem de família
muito humilde
vários dos meus amigos lá existiram na
escola no meio do caminho escolheram
outros caminhos foram pro pra para o
lado errado e eu precisei de muita
persistência muita perseverança para
poder continuar ali e hoje poder estar
aqui falando isso pra vocês
foi essa mesma persistência que também
me ajudou a encarar são paulo a descer
lá na rodoviária do tietê sem sem saber
nadar naquela época não tinha o laser
não tinha google eu lembro de ter
comprado aquele guia cidade de são paulo
que mais parecia um tijolo né e começar
a ler um mapa aprendendo em são paulo a
partir daquele mapa
precisei ser muito insistente e ao longo
da minha jornada como empreendedor é
essa é a que eu acho mais bacana
também precisei de muita persistência e
dê uma pitadinha de teimosia é não é
fácil tentar uma vez quebrar um negócio
juntar os cacos levantar tentar
novamente colocar outra empresa em pé
quebrado de novo a estava ficando bom e
superpoder com essa super poder eu sou o
super quebrador de empresas e começar de
novo e aí dá certo e no meu caso e eu
gosto muito de falar de mim porque eu
acho que quando você fala de você que
quem está ao seu lado se consegue traçar
os melhores paralelos teimosia e
perseverança são dois super poderes
muito próximos
qual é a diferença entre eles
a diferença entre um e outro aqui a hora
que você erra você começa
desenvolver essa capacidade de onde foi
que eu errei
será que eu consigo fazer um pouquinho
diferente e olha é diferente nem melhor
o melhor ele vem com o tempo vem com a
prática
será que eu consigo fazer um pouquinho
diferente da próxima vez e aí você tenta
de novo se você consegue fazer um
pouquinho diferente da próxima vez você
está sendo persistente
se você continua fazendo errando e
continua igual
você tá sendo teimoso e acho que com
todos com todo mundo que eu converso é a
mesma coisa
é tudo muito próximo que precisa de
muito conhecimento precisa de olhar pra
dentro é e cada um
muitas das vezes a teimosia que me
atrapalha numa determinada situação é a
mesma teimosia que vai ajudar outra
pessoa numa situação diferente
é por isso que é importante essa busca
pelo autoconhecimento de olhar para
dentro de si entender do que você é
feito o que te faz único
qual é o ponto fraco qual é o ponto
forte no que você é bom que você precisa
melhorar e ao e ao exibir se descobrindo
você começa a compartilhar com as
pessoas aquilo que você pode contribuir
começa a buscar ajuda de outras pessoas
daquilo que você precisa melhorar
então como eu já disse é uma jornada não
é fácil
mais do que nunca vale aquela máxima que
o importante é nem sempre é o destino
mas é aproveitar a viagem curtir a
paisagem então essa busca pelos super
poderes
ela é uma jornada é uma eterna jornada
nós vamos chegar lá adiante lá na frente
da vida e por muito provavelmente não
teremos chegado ao fim dela então tem
que tem que ser um pouco persistente não
é fácil nem todos conseguem chegar lá
então
é de mim eu olho muito quando a pessoa
teimosa quando a pessoa persistente
então eu vejo muitas pessoas mais velhas
que ainda são mais teimosas do que
persistentes outras pessoas mais jovens
que já aprenderam já se conheceram e
ficaram mais perseverantes mas o que eu
posso dizer para vocês aqui vale muito a
pena
vale muito a pena olhar para dentro de
você entender aquilo que você é feito
onde você pode melhorar e continuar a
seguir em frente
eu sou fabrício super teimoso
trabalhando e me esforçando muito para
um dia ser um super persistente
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]